[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler d'un
sujet délicat et dramatique la haine des
juifs la haine des juifs le sujet
traverse l'histoire deux mille ans de
notre histoire depuis l'antijudaïsme au
temps de jésus et des pharisiens
hypocrites les croisades la judéophobie
protestante de martin luther le
fanatisme antijuive des almohades en
andalousie les protocoles des sages de
sion et les progrès des pogroms de la
russie tsariste la shoah et
l'antisémitisme contemporain avec ses
différentes variantes sociologique
religieuses idéologiques islamo
gauchistes anti sioniste bref une
histoire qui dure et perdure partout
dans le monde et notamment en france
avec lé meurtre d'ilan halimi sarah
halimi mihai knoll des enfants juifs
d'une école à toulouse et selon le
dernier sondage de fondapol et
l'american jewish committee qui constate
la progression des sentiments
antisémites au sein de la population
française de tout cela nous allons
chercher à comprendre cette permanence
morbide avec mes invités que je vous
présente
manuel valls vous êtes ancien premier
ministre et vous connaissez parfaitement
ces questions
barbara cassin vous êtes écrivaine de
l'académie française à vos côtés pascal
ory vous êtes historien également de
l'académie française et frédéric
salat-baroux êtes avocat et céistes
on
[Musique]
vient de voir la citation de pierre
douglas la haine des juifs la
judéophobie
l'antisémitisme c'est toujours un sujet
une histoire sans fin comment vous
expliquez ça pascal ory
je termine mon livre en disant que c'est
une histoire sans fin sans prend
vraiment l'air mais parce que c'est une
histoire qui est un commencement et pour
moi c'est une thèse que défend mais
j'essaye de documenter c'est pour ça que
j'ai sous titré mon livre et c'est
historique je suis pas un historien pas
philosophe pas sociologues etc pour moi
ça se noue avec le christianisme ce qui
suppose que je démontre d'abord j'essaie
de le démontrer qu'il n'ya pas une
question juive parce que l'expression
question juive pour moi c'est une
question antijuive dire que les justes
rockeur d'une cale en blé distinction
par rapport à jean paul sartre là on
peut en parler longuement parlé c'est
gentil delà de tous les sens de mon
agacement devant le titre de sa trop de
trucs là non il n'y a pas de questions
juives avant le christianisme il y à
d'autres types de rapports
fondamentalement politique c'est ça que
j'ai découvert un ermite en écrivant ce
livre c'est que c'est une histoire
politique dans l'antiquité polythéistes
il n'y a pas une question juive
contamment ce qu'on dit parfois en
revanche elle se pose paradoxalement
dans la proximité entre le christianisme
et le judaïsme ce que là c'est
irréparable
alors manuel valls qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette vue de l'historien je
suis modeste plein d'humilité face aux
travaux des historiens
que je lis évidemment ça m'intéresse
parce que je pense que d'une certaine
manière
l'antisémitisme la haine des juifs la
judéophobie qu'au nom des expressions
différentes illustre des maux de notre
société et quand les sociétés vont mal
l'antisémitisme montescot
l'antisémitisme au monde c'est au fond
une description terrible des défis que
nous avons est au fond moi je me suis
intéresse à cette question parce que
elle illustre aussi dans notre époque
plus contemporaines des moments de
césure de basculement dans notre
histoire moderne
évidemment tout cela vient de très loin
ça vient d'être rappelé mais c'est
évidemment la sphère dreyfus qui arrive
moment de la publication
de la france juive de drummond c'est
blum au pouvoir à des manifestations
anti juives c'est évidemment les choix
de pétain et de la collaboration
mais ce sont aussi d'autres moments
comme et aaron ian kelly beach l'avait
très bien démontré suite à la guerre des
six jours et puis évidemment c'est cet
antisémitisme cette haine des juifs qui
basculent sur la question d'israël et de
l'antisionisme on va rentrer dans
explosé dans nos banlieues en va
explorer toute cette histoire mais sur
le côté sans fin barbara cassin vous
avez vous penser pareil je pense qu'en
effet il ya un début net
qui est
qu'ils ont le fait que le peuple juif
soit considérée comme déicide donc le
christianisme ça existe comme ça et
alors je ne dis pas que le pape actuel
ou que les chrétiens
que j'aime pense cela pense comme ça
mais je pense qu'en tout cas c'est un
vrai début
alors que cette histoire soit sans fin
ce qui est sans fin à mon sens c'est
le mauvais rapport à l'autre le racisme
dont l'antisémitisme fait partie à mes
yeux alors frédéric salat-baroux vous
êtes penché sur cette question à travers
un personnage historique manuel valls on
a parlé léon blum est ce qu a votre avis
il a ça jouer dans sa carrière politique
dans son rôle être humain évidemment il
a été victime
il a été de la collaboration et de même
étaient en camp de concentration
mais est ce que cette dimension était
prégnante chez lui c'est à dire le
l'antisémitisme plus que l'identité
juive je crois que très peu de personnes
ont affronté autant d'antisémitisme que
lui la violence des attaques d'ailleurs
sur tous les terrains de l'antisémitisme
la richesse la manipulation le
socialisme le rapport complexe au
capitalisme personnes affronter même
d'ailleurs dans les choses les plus
irrationnelles de l'antisémitisme terre
cette association entre juifs féminité
ambiguïté sexuelle existait aussi par
exemple quand caen morath dit en parlant
de blum
lafifi blum baptisé
baptisé au scalpel on retrouve tout
toute cette problématique donc il a
évidemment affronter ça dans une période
où tout l'antisémitisme se canalise le
l'antisémitisme traditionnel mais
également l'antisémitisme de cette
période bouleversé par le capitalisme et
la montée du socialisme mais malgré tout
il a aussi une caractéristique qui est
très juive c'est à dire que à aucun
moment il ne donnait l'apparence d'être
touché par l'antisémitisme et quand il
est lynché quasiment le 13 février 36 il
parlait de ce moment en dix ans ce petit
incident dont j'ai fait l'objet barbara
cassin frédéric salat-baroux vient de
signaler que on associer la figure du
juif et du féminin vous avez rencontrés
çà voudra à travers la vous-même m alors
allez-y alors allez-y et d'où ça vient
non ça vient de ce que du mauvais
rapport à l'autre justement
et là de l'assignation de l'autre comme
un mauvais autres mais je pense beaucoup
hannah arendt j'ai publié mois les
écrits juifs d'hannah arendt que je
trouve un livre absolument magnifique
recueil absolument magnifique et alors
elle raconte que bombe à être juive
on l'est elle s'en est aperçu quand on
lui a dit saad juive en gros mais je
dirais que elle pense aussi qu'être
femme s'est pas fondamentalement
différent c'est à dire qu'on s'en impose
qu'on s'en aperçoit quand on dit pas
forcément sale femme ou belle femme mais
quand on vous dit femmes donc vous êtes
en train de dire c'est que pour un art
inte il faut réagir quand on est femme
en tant que femme et quand on est juif
en tant que juif absolument et puis
précisé louis jobard ce que je veux dire
c'est que il ne s'agit jamais d'une
assignation d'essence vous n'êtes pas
pour hannah arendt en tout cas en tout
cas valeur pour moi je ne sais pas vous
n'êtes pas juif point ni femme point
vous êtes
un être complexe juifs femmes hommes
ange
prolétaires philosophe écrivaine comme
vous dites bon tout ça existe et doit
coexister et quand on s'adresse à vous
en tant que est bien la grande leçon
d'hannah arendt qu'elle tenait de sa
mère c répond en tant que voilà donc
elle dit très très nettement qu'elle ne
savait pas qu'elle était juive jusqu'à
ce qu'on la traite de sale juive ce qui
veut dire enfin je ne sais pas si là on
serait d'accord là dessus c'est à dire
sur cette assignation de réciproque si
vous voulez et je pense que par rapport
aux as que moi je considère être femme
je ne m'en aperçois vraiment bien que
quand on ne le dit que quand je suis une
femme pour quelqu'un
sait où est le désaccord entre vous et
pascal ory par rapport à l'assignation
réciproque c'est à dire que je pense que
vous fin je ne sais pas je ne veux pas
parler pour vous mais je n'ai pas lu ça
exactement pour moi c'est une
assignation pas du tout réciproque la
question c'est la question chrétienne
c'est à dire que le christianisme ne
peut pas nier qu'il a une source juive
et il est ébranlée puis pour ne pas
s'effondrer il est amené à devenir
haineux à l'égard de ceux qui refuse
l'évidence qui est que le peuple juif
doit devenir peuple chrétien et ça
recommence avec mahomet sur d'autres
bases lyon par l'importance des tribus
juives à médine et c est même colère et
dans le cas de lutter faut préciser tout
de suite qu'une demi d'hypothèses c'est
que si ça change c'est grâce aux
protestants plutôt calviniste mais aussi
du terrien mais lutter à la fin de sa
vie qui a au contraire insisté au début
de sa vie sur il ya même écrit un texte
qui s'appelait ainsi que jésus est né
juif ll fallait le faire au xvième
siècle bien lutter tourner violemment
anti-juifs quand il se rend compte que
alors que le protestantisme et
vétérotestamentaire donc on reconnaît la
culture protestante encore aujourd'hui
par rapport à la culture catholique
standard à ce que l'ancien testament
elle connaît et bien c'est celle juifs
mais justement innues à ne pas
comprendre qu'ils doivent devenir
protesté pascal ory justement sur ce
point vous dites dans votre livre la
judéophobie a pour date de naissance le
christianisme mais depuis l'église a
fait un formidable travail réparateur
avec jean xxiii le concile vatican ii la
déclaration nostra et athée
comment se fait-il que le relais était
épris aussi facilement par d'autres
acteurs religieux politiques
idéologiques comme je prends cette
formule d'adorno qui dit que
l'antisémitisme s'est répandu comme une
rumeurs nauséabondes qui courent
toujours à propos des juifs comment vous
expliquez cette haine des juifs comme un
stigmate de l'humanité écoutez c'est le
sens de mon livre la première partie
après l'introduction sur lequel je ne
reviens pas une deuxième fois qui est
quand même de prouver qu'il n'ya pas de
question juive dans l'antiquité alors
que certains pensent le contraire
j'essaie de démontrer que c'est une
erreur parce que c'est un chronique en
revanche vous avez un premier stade qui
est un stade d'antijudaïsme religieux
chrétiens et musulmans avec des nuances
suivant les époques et dans il ya un
moment où où le grand accueil des juifs
se fait en pologne pays catholique etc
bon et puis ce qui me paraît plus
intéressant dans ce que je dis à la
limite c'est la deuxième époque que
j'appelle l'antisémitisme effectivement
là on passe de l'assignation religieuse
à l'assignation raciale et ce qui est
terrible c'est que le monde moderne
croit à la science avec un grand s la
science démontre qu'il ya des races elle
d'ailleurs démontre même moment qu'à des
classes et la lutte des races avec les
places sont deux notions absolument
contemporaine et 1830 à peu près dire la
lutte des classes c'est guizot c'est pas
marx est bon bref donc le monde moderne
évacue dieu et catastrophe on continue à
haïr les juifs et parce qu'il ya 1500
ans de substrats anti juif qui peut
fonctionner qui peut être modernisé en
fonction d'un certain nombre d'éléments
économique ou politique nouveau en
particulier la cristallisation nationale
et ce génie spécifique qui est celui du
nationalisme que personnellement j'ai
consacré un livre entier à ça je ne
confonds pas avec le national mais le
nationalisme qui comme par hasard n'est
essentiellement france à la fin du 19e
siècle le mot d'ailleurs apparaît à ce
moment là c'est un moyen en particulier
de récupérer ses traditions xénophobe
pas seulement d'ailleurs anti juif mais
en particulier anti juives mais dans un
sens qui n'a plus besoin de dieu il
suffit d'avoir la nation et en tenant la
race ça fonctionne et le complotisme
qu'on voit aujourd'hui le jeu si dans
mon livre un sondage auprès des gilets
jaunes très intéressant sur le complot
juif environ 40% des gilets jaunes
interrogées pensent qu'il ya un complot
juif nous sommes à notre époque tout ça
ça vient du moyen-âge dans les limites
et c réactive et sur d'autres bases tout
à fait alors on va passer sur le plan
politique avec frédéric salat-baroux
pardon et manuel valls
manuel valls vous êtes un homme
politique de premier plan a été premier
ministre
ce qui vous donne une vision politique
intéressante est majeur ça oui et
frédéric salat-baroux ve vous êtes
avocat mais vous avez fréquenté et de
quelle place puisqu'il a été secrétaire
général de l'elysée est-ce que vous avez
constaté dans le monde politique cette
rumeurs nauséabondes
qui veut manuel valls oui moi je suis
enfin d'abord je pense c'est très
important ça vient d'être fait de
manière lumineuse par deux grands
intellectuels
les origines de cet antisémitisme et je
veux insister sur le sur ce qui vient
d'être dit par pascal ory c'était le
basculement me semble-t-il du 19e siècle
où
s'accumulent la notion de race
la notion de classe et le surgissement
du nationalisme et à partir de là c'est
là où je perds mois une distinction
entre le racisme en général et la
particularité de
l'antisémitisme car le racisme désigne
en fonction de la couleur de peau ou des
religions c'est vrai mais des êtres
qu'on considère comme inférieurs c'est
le cas aussi dans l'antisémitisme mais
se rajoute à l'antisémitisme le
complotisme c'est à dire le rôle que les
juifs exercerait dans l'économie ça
c'est le capitalisme avec notamment les
scandales la banque rothschild etc donc
on utilisa drummond de ce point de vue
là jouent un rôle très important et
qu'on retrouve tout au long du xxème
siècle et se rajoute à cela un autre
élément je réponds à votre question qui
est la naissance d'israël et la victoire
de 1967 où là c'est être entre
guillemets inférieur où cette minorité
qui complotent dans l'ombre gagne des
guerres et à une forme de puissance dans
le monde qui ne cesse depuis de
s'établir et donc dans le monde
politique ce que je constate que vous
avez printemps matin oui mais je le
constate notamment sur le terrain je
suis alors maire d'evry dans la région
parisienne où le nouvel antisémitisme le
mot est mal trouvé l'antisémitisme
retrouve une vigueur dans les
populations arabo musulmane d'origine
arabo-musulmane dans une partie de la
gauche et de la critique de l'action
d'israël où la question israélo
palestinienne
on bascule là dans l'anti sionisme qui
est ayant calé oui je l'avais je le
répète écrit aussi au front qui est
l'antisémitisme de salon et de confort
pour ceux qui considèrent que les juifs
pose toujours un problème et là ils se
fondent et anciennement sur la question
israélo palestinienne et donc du coup
dans des fréquentations en ville dans
des réunions avec des partenaires
politiques je vois en effet naître sous
la forme du rejet d'israël et après on
retrouve sous les termes les plus
bestiaux dans les combats que je mène
presque personnelle d'ailleurs contre
dieudonné et soral c'est à dire la
synthèse de l'extrême gauche et de
l'extrême droite sur cette question là
et qui à un moment a pris une proportion
de notre pays
qu'on n'imagine pas ce que ce sont des
dizaines de milliers personnes qui
manifestent contre israël en 2014 à
propos de gaza ce sont des millions de
vues sur des textes antisémites ce sont
des spectacles antisémites de dieudonné
dans des zénith d'ailleurs à ses
intérêts sociaux avec des jeunes des
places moyenne des petits employés les
fonctionnaires et donc il ya un
mouvement anti sémites et il n'est pas
étonnant d'ailleurs de retrouver souvent
les mêmes leaders les mêmes personnes
qui sont derrière les réseaux sociaux ou
des gens nouveaux dans des
manifestations dg les jaunes ou à
l'occasion des tests comploter retrouve
aussi sur la question du virus de la
copie 19 dont donc il ya donc vous le
retrouvez en effet dans une partie dans
les extrêmes et pas seulement de la
classe politique puisque c'est elle à
votre question tout à fait vous frédéric
salat baroux moi je partage tous peuvent
tout à fait ce qui a été dit mais je
voudrais revenir juste sur la
problématique des origines et puis le
mystère de l'antisémitisme il ya
évidemment la problématique de
l'antériorité par rapport à la religion
chrétienne mais déjà dans la bible terre
quand on prend le livre d'esther le
personnage dahmane qui s'adresse à
assier russe en lui disant il y a dans
votre royaume un peuple qui est par tout
un peuple qui obéit à d'autres lois que
la loi commune vous roi vous ne pouvez
pas accepter que ça se passe ainsi et il
propose le génocide on est déjà à cet
instant sur ce côté mystérieux avec
toutes les thématiques qui sont déjà les
thématiques de l'antisémitisme et qu'on
va retrouver cette irrationalité donc il
ya à l'origine dès l'origine même c'est
dans votre livre pascal ory 7 c'est très
intéressant de
ça fait du bien d'ailleurs de chercher à
rationaliser c'est-à-dire l'antériorité
le refus l'uniformité je rajouterais là
le destin de rupture du judaïsme dès
l'origine mais malgré tout
aussi incompréhensible parce que je
crois qu'il ya un moment il faut prendre
un peu de distance l'antisémitisme est
incompréhensible aussi incompréhensible
qu'il le soit il est original et
effectivement on le retrouve et c'est
toute la problématique encore maintenant
avec une acuité extrême merci
[Musique]
alors à travers les siècles et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il y ait un désaccord sur ce
qui attise la haine des juifs on vient
de voir ce que dit stefan zweig ce
serait du soin au fait qu'ils
s'intègrent trop soit qu'ils forment une
communauté à part et sont rétifs à la
civilisation
quelle place le jacinto
aujourd'hui comme hier par rapport à
cette dualité
qu'est-ce que alors première remarque
qui veut noyer son chien l'accusé de la
rage si vous êtes sinophobe de tendance
anti juives vous trouverez toujours une
bonne raison un jour ils seront trop pas
simuler un autre jour inassimilable
sourire mais là qu'on a dit les juifs
ont ce problème là est-ce qu'on se
montre trop où est ce qu'il faut se
lâcher mais la réponse de l'historien
swiss re est à dire la modernité
politique s'accompagne ll causes
conséquences de l'émancipation des juifs
d'abord tolérance dans comme par hasard
dans les pays protestants plutôt
calviniste ça commence en fait à
amsterdam en 16e siècle et ça montera
jusqu'à 1791 heureux comme dieu en
france et dans et du coup tous ceux qui
se considèrent à tort ou à raison or ce
qui est content en histoire comme en
politique actuelle ans et la température
ressentie c'est par la température
réelle si je me considère comme humilié
comme exploités comme dominer comme
victime de la tendance historique
évidemment ça peut cristalliser en 30
une dizaine au faux billets vous avez un
certain abeba ruelle qui est typiquement
la victime de la révolution française
c'est un ancien jésuite entre
parenthèses on ne dit pas toujours
c'est assez intéressant jésuites ont été
aussi l'objet d'une théorie complotiste
jean-paul yaakov l'avait bien montré
donc c'est un ancien jésuite qui dit la
révolution française c'est l'oeuvre d'un
complot maçonnique est un des premiers à
le dire bon et puis quelques années plus
tard il prétend avoir reçu apparemment
ce serait inexact mais peu importe une
lettre d'un sélecteur d'origine
italienne qui lui dit monsieur l'abbé
génial mais vous avez oublié les juifs
est évidemment une nouvelle édition de
l'abbé barruel complot judéo maçonnique
mais tout simplement parce que ça vient
du vide de la victime par excellence du
monde moderne et qui cherchent
évidemment une cause quasiment
transcendante à savoir le complot les
illuminati moi j'ai quand même été très
étonné d'entendre mes enfants parler des
illuminati parce que l'isi miniature on
a parlé beaucoup en 1788 si vous voulez
et voilà que ça ressurgit vous pouvez
dire deux mots sur cet immortel ce
jambes c'était l'idée que le monde
serait gouverné par une élite
complotistes secrète c'est en fait la
déformation de la mouvement maçonnique
mais les protocoles des sages de sion
qui sont aujourd'hui commencer j'allais
dire que nos années en vente libre au
proche orient aujourd'hui avec internet
on s'en fiche qui sont en principe c'est
accessible par tout le monde même pas au
proche orient mais enfin les protocoles
des sages de sion c'est simplement la
déformation parlant l'anti judaïsme
orthodoxe puisque ça vient de russie une
réalité objective comme la révolution
française c'est une réalité objective à
savoir la création du mouvement sioniste
c'est exactement donc vous avez herzeele
traduction évidemment il ya un complot
des juifs pour dominer le monde oui
frédéric salat-baroux alors sur cette
question de l'entité bêtise par rapport
lié soir aux juifs qui réussissent trop
soir aux juifs qui essaie de ne pas se
montrer qu est ce que vous en pensez
je crois que au coeur de la question de
l'antisémitisme et le livre de pascal
ory l'expriment très bien dès qu'un
régime et dès qu'une société cherche en
réalité l'unité et l'uniformité à ce
moment là le juif devient une source de
terreur c'est à dire la volonté des
juifs de garder leur identité religieuse
est vécu comme une atteinte inacceptable
et c'est pour ça que plus les régimes
ont une vocation universelle
c'est très bien expliqué sur rome c'est
très bien expliqué aussi sur les grandes
religions à vocation universelle le
catholicisme
l'islam est évidemment le nazisme qui
est la phase extrême à ce moment là la
volonté des juifs tout simplement de
rester fidèles alors leur religion
original est inacceptable et
insoutenable et donc plus les régimes
ont cette ambition unificatrice et
unitaires plus le juif à ce moment là
est un problème et on retrouve ça
effectivement tout au long de l'histoire
alors barbara cassin j'aimerais avoir
votre avis j'avais en ont eu une fois
débat ici au cours d'une émission ses
aigus gouvernent le monde et les plus
grands écrivains echl et châteaubriant
et cetera voltaire etc certains qui
n'ont pas de penchant antisémite mais il
ya toujours des remarques antisémites
dans leurs oeuvres alors la question que
je voulais vous poser c'est que georges
perec considère que le juif est synonyme
de question de remise en question est ce
que cet élément là est susceptible de
créer ce sentiment raciste sentiment de
xénophobie parce que sade dieu et vous
il se soit ça mais dont je vous pose la
question mais je voudrais enfin réagir
deux ou trois choses que j'ai entendu si
vous le permettez d'abord
je ne crois pas que
l'identité juive soit seulement une
question de religion et c'est pas parce
que les juifs tiennent à leur religion
qu'on est antisémite
personnellement dans ma famille si vous
voulez qui est juive cassin est un non
juif
jeunes on connaît pas de religieux en
revanche
mes parents se sont enfuis pendant la
guerre et beaucoup de ma famille
ont disparu
donc ça n'est pas un problème de
religion je crois sauf séminal et pour
certains ça allait pas pour une lettre
pour certains voient l'arrivée dans son
ensemble oui et c'est un problème de
religion à partir du moment où on a
intérêt à la racine c'est-à-dire peuple
déicide
juifs chrétiens juifs et même je dirais
catholique ou des bars bon donc là
d'accord mais après pas seulement c'est
d'abord je voudrais faire remarquer une
chose c'est que c'est très difficile de
définir qui est juif déjà je suis désolé
mais ça ne paraît pas du tout une
question réglée parce que elle sera
jamais réglé il ya très bien on met
alors disons le je vais vous rappeler
ses traits maudissent une anecdote une
anecdote je vais vous dire lorsque
l'état d'israël a été créé ben gourion a
demandé à 200 personnalités juives du
monde entier et de lui dire qui est
juive louis et son ami bialik lui dit
arrête avec ces conneries ça ce que ça
n'a aucun sens là bien sûr donc c'est
qu'on est bien d'accord là dessus on est
d'accord chez lui sur la remise enquête
j'ai pas vraiment entendu ça jusqu'à
maintenant je veux dire ça me paraît
très intéressant de le dire 1 j'avais un
oncle qui s'appelait henry barucq qui
était fils d'une chrétienne bon du fils
du non juive on va dire elle même fille
d'une non juives bon et donc qu'ils
n'étaient pas juifs sur sa carte
d'identité et il a écrit juive de coeur
bon au moment de la guerre ça voulait
dire quelque chose donc ça veut dire
quand même que l'identité juive est
quelque chose d'assez complexe alors si
vous voulez je réponds maintenant
partout ce détour à votre cas la
question que vous m'avez posé c'est à
dire est ce que la remise en cause
la remise en question la critique peut
être considérée comme juive j'aimerais
beaucoup que ça soit le cas c'est le cas
par exemple quand on dit de quelqu'un
qu'il a l'esprit talmudiste pour c'est
une manière de dire et il
il pose des questions qui succède à des
questions est
certaine manière il et philologue c'est
mon cas alors que et travail sur les
textes il rampe dans les textes avec la
kribi d'une limace myope ça c'est une
phrase de nietzsche qui ne s'applique
qui s'appliquait au moins autant ou
philologue allemand qu'il était co
philologue juifs bon donc il ya un
certain rapport aux textes ça c'est
certain je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas une
culture juive des cultures juives mais
il me semble que la définition même du
juif
on sait bien qu'on ne la donne pas et
c'est même peut-être pour ça qu'il y
aura toujours des antisémites je
n'oublie pas que à la sortie de je
n'oublie pas une phrase d'un harem que
je trouvais génial elle était là à la
sortie d'une visite que faisaient des
classes que faisait une classe avec
beaucoup de noirs dans cette classe aux
états unis au musée juif et elle
entendait un petit black dire je ne
savais pas que les blacks étaient juifs
c'est parfait c'est à dire qu'il ya
vraiment quelque chose de l'ordre deux
mais bien du paria et c'est comme ça que
elle définit et donc le paria n'est pas
seulement un paria juif ça peut être
toutes sortes de parias ou alors la
première grande date je suis
parfaitement d'accord c'est quand même
jésus on va dire et le déicide et c est
la deuxième grande date je suis là aussi
parfaitement d'accord c'est la création
de l'état d'israël ça c'est autour de
ces deux grandes dates que disons
l'antisémitisme peut se construire voilà
alors écoutez pascal ory j'aimerais une
précision de votre part
aujourd'hui les juifs
exégètes de la bible s'intéresse à jésus
c'était pas le cas et les juifs
s'intéressent de plus en plus à jésus et
à la période des pharisiens est ce que
vous sentez
historiquement une évolution de ce côté
là à savoir que le dialogue judéo
chrétien a véritablement progresser et
jésus et même accepté comme une figure
juive et chez les juifs et gérer
chrétiens alors écoutez le dialogue
judéo chrétien moi je le vois j'ai fait
allusion tout à l'heure naître chez les
protestants à cause de cette nature
vétérotestamentaire à quoi pouvaient
s'ajouter d'ailleurs surtout pour les
calvinistes dans des pays comme la
france la solidarité de persécuter qui
expliquent le chambon-sur-lignon où
dieulefit des villes françaises une
forte proportion de protestants et comme
comme par hasard accueilli des enfants
juifs pendant la guerre donc il ya tout
ça
mais après le dialogue mettra du temps à
passer aux catholiques c'est tout
l'intérêt après la seconde guerre
mondiale donc la lire il faut une shoah
pour ça j'ai traitement il ya un peu en
mesure de le dire fois le choix pour ça
avec jules isaac par exemple où
effectivement jules isaac qui est le pur
produit de la culture
historiographique française l'équipe c a
été rappelé à l'ordre ben oui mais vous
êtes juif et d'ailleurs on vous exclu de
l'université
jules isaac vers 1942 il fuit avec une
valise sur les routes d'auvergne ils
étaient deux en avants président du jury
de l'agrégation d'histoire c'est ça
c'est ça l'histoire du monde s'était
brutalement tout ce qui paraissait
évident les juifs étaient intégrés pour
nom léon blum et c est donc élu il ya eu
un dialogue il ya eu un dialogue
effectivement mais par rapport au grand
mouvement s'est encore assez peu de
choses et voir une des découvertes que
j'ai fait en écrivant ce livre on sait
le résultat d'une quarantaine d'années
de prise de notes de terrain sait que la
deuxième époque l'époque antisémites à
troisième époque étant effectivement lié
à la naissance de l'état d'israël c'est
notre troisième âge
la période antisémite est elle commence
bien avec l'émancipation et donc vous
avez quand même un mouvement profond de
libération qui concerne une grande
partie de la planète en tous les cas de
l'occident et ça se termine par la shoah
c'est presque vertigineux de se dire ça
on commence par les calvinistes on
commence par ses dialogues qui se
multiplient à partir du xvième siècle ça
se termine quand même très mal alors
évidemment vous avez la chute finale du
nazisme mais on a quand même frôlé pire
des catastrophes donc ceux qui pensent
qu'il ya un sens de l'histoire peuvent
s'interroger sur ce sens et puis comme
incité pérec
moi je pense plutôt à l'histoire avec sa
grande hache un mot là-dessus sur ce
sens de l'histoire manuel valls est ce
que les tragiques forcément et cette
manière donc nous vivrons et nous vivons
avec l'antisémitisme raison de plus pour
le combattre d'autant plus que c'était
le sens de votre question précédente
nous avons à la fois là où les juifs
sont totalement assimilé émancipé
sans signe distinctif
particulier grâce à la révolution
française grâce à napoléon grâce à la
république ils subissent deux chocs
majeurs
drummond et dreyfus et 1940 est là et la
déportation et de l'autre côté là où il
les juifs sont organisés très compris
les organisations politiques comme le
bund qui sont en ghetto c'est le cas
évidemment dans toute l'europe de l'est
qui sont aussi persécutés donc du coup
le juge se retrouve quel que soit
l'attitude qui est la sienne ou l'année
l'histoire se trouve persécuté pour des
raisons profondes qui ont été expliquées
depuis le début de cette émission ce qui
montre en effet la part tragique de
l'histoire et la puissance de cet
antisémitisme
[Musique]
alors on va passer à la france france
contemporaine vous venez de voir la
citation de l'ancien garde des sceaux
robert badinter qui constatent à
l'unisson de la plupart des observateurs
la renaissance d'un antisémitisme
proclamé en france d'un antisémitisme
meurtrier et criminels quels sont les
ingrédients de cet antisémitisme que
dénonce robert badinter manuel valls que
je l'évoqué il y un instant et s'était
rappelée y compris à pascal ory à
travers la publication du protocole des
sages de sion sous forme de livres
vendus au caire dont une proche et le
moyen orient voire même de série et de
téléfilms et relayée ensuite par les
réseaux sociaux ou par les paraboles
c'est sur la question israélo
palestinienne et donc est
essentiellement et notamment je le
répète par la victoire d'israël
c'est-à-dire ce n'est plus israël qui
recueille les rescapés de la shoah
victimes du nazisme et de l'histoire et
de la différence c'est un peuple qui
gagne et qui s'imposent et donc du coup
il ya là tous les ferments pour une
nouvelle
vigueur pour l'antisémitisme et on
retrouve donc en france et il y à une
année déterminante c'est ce qui est
rappelé c'est 2014 il y a deux
manifestations de masse plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes une en
janvier et une pendant l'été dix jours
de colère par rapport à gaza organisée
par l'extrême gauche dans lequel se
mêlent
l'extrême droite les personnages que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure avec l'idée
d'ailleurs pour certains groupes d'aller
rue des rosiers et ça se fait avec
notamment à l'été et nous vivrons avec
barrage 15,9 qui à ce moment là ministre
de l'intérieur s'est on trie pour la
première fois de manière ouverte à paris
mort aux juifs et donc à partir de la
question palestinienne se noue une
alliance
invraisemblable mais nouvelle partager
évidemment avec des nuances entre
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite 1
quelle on retrouve non plus
l'antisémitisme puisque ce n'est pas le
mot qui est utilisé mais le rejet
profond
d'israël du sionisme et donc c'est la
haine des juifs qui est annuel valls ce
mort aux juifs qu'on a entendus dans les
rues de france est ce que quelque part
pour parler comme un psychanalyste la
gagne a autorisé le passage à l'acte et
ça expliquait lé meurtre d'ilan halimi
le madame halimi de madame knoll des
enfants juifs de l'école au tsar a tort
est ce que vous voyez un lien comme ces
idées qui gouvernent le monde tout le
monde le sait ici les idées
peuvent tuer est en tout cas le peuvent
proposer des passages à l'acte il y a eu
fric salat baroux a connu aussi cette
époque il y a eu et je regrette sous un
gouvernement de gauche en 2001 2002 une
peur quand on a eu toute une série
d'actes antisémites c'était lionel
jospin qui dépendent ministre daniel
vaillant qui était ministre de
l'intérieur jean était paralysée on
s'attaque à des synagogues à des
compatriotes qui portait la kippa
pourquoi mais parce que les actes
venaient essentiellement
de concitoyens de confession ou de
culture musulmane c'est à dire le
prolétariat le nouveau prolétariat qui
qui par essence ne peut pas avoir tort
et donc il y avait une réaction de recul
et quand il ya eu des assassinats
notamment dit dan halimi ou quand une
famille juive de créteil a été attaquée
violée à la fin de l'année 2013 seule la
communauté juive a réagi j'ai comme
premier ministre marque et mama ma
frayeur à l'assemblée nationale en
disant mais il n'y a pas de mobilisation
et il ya une prise de conscience un
basculement
c'est en janvier 2015 avec l'attak de
l'hyper cacher porte de vincennes après
les meurtres à charlie hebdo est à
montrouge où là on se rend compte que ce
n'est pas que le problème des juifs mais
c'est un problème beaucoup plus vaste
mais le passage à l'acte il est
construit en effet progressivement par
toute une série alors l'idée de texte ce
qui fait que par exemple les barbares
qui a six qui assassine halimi on les
retrouve torturant et assassinant halimi
on aurait pu les torturer on aurait pu
les trouver pardon quelques né après
manuel valls dont les attentats je veux
aller un peu plus loin avec vous est ce
qu'il ya une responsabilité politique
dans l'est au début des années 2000
dans la l'exil en quelque sorte des
juifs qui quittent les banlieues
françaises
est ce qu'on a donné un os à ronger avec
le conflit israélo-palestinien aux
jeunes des banlieues il ya une
responsabilité historique politique de
la gauche de ma propre famille politique
parce que là le président était jacques
chirac et le premier ministre était
lionel josse au début jusqu en 2002 mais
mais mais c'est quelque chose qui va
bien au delà il ya une responsabilité de
la gauche je les jeux les jeux les vécus
c'est à ce moment là que comme maire
d'evry moi je décide comme jeu
parlementaire de de m'engager dans ce
dans ce dans ce dans ce débat parce que
je vois bien la question de
l'antisémitisme comme toujours est un
miroir terrible pour notre société et je
pense qu'une grande partie de la gauche
se brise pas seulement là dessus et les
questions européennes sociale évidemment
mais se brise sur ce sur ce sujet là il
ya une cassure qui qui restera à tout
jamais de mon point de vue il rêvait
diable et que d'ailleurs je veux pas du
tout parlé de moi dans cette affaire
mais quand même que je ressens jusqu'au
bout vous savez précisément en 2017 je
vis une élection légitime par contre
parler de ces détails où je suis réélu
de très peu mais je je connais une
campagne dieudonné candidat contre moi
mon épouse de l'époque était juive je
connais une campagne d'un antisémitisme
moi qui ne suis pas juif mais mais mais
invraisemblable sous le regard
distant de beaucoup goguenarde une
partie de la presse ne se rendant pas
compte que ce que au fond cet épisode
veut dire de tous par rapport à tous
ceux qui se sont engagés politiquement
dans ce combat donc oui il ya une
responsabilité et cet os à ronger oui
c'était ouf on a utilisé la question
palestinienne au delà de la vision qu'on
peut avoir sur ce conflit comme un os
rangés comme un élément qui unifiée en
plus on aurait dit dans les années 70 ou
80 un nouveau front de classe dans un
langage néo-marxiste à nous en classe
pour tous les déshérités de la terre et
donc des banlieues point de vue de
l'historien là dessus parce que c'est
une nouveauté ce que vient de dire
manuellement c'est pas tout à fait une
nouveauté ce que je dis dans le livre
pertinemment où on pense que la
convergence entre une certaine extrême
gauche lille une certaine mais j'ajoute
extrême c'est le mot extrême club
d'indre et une certaine extrême droite
datent du 19e siècle je rappelle que
chez fourier chez proudhon
ch et surtout les blanquistes et blanc
qui sait aujourd'hui où quelques
historiens ou ceux qui comme manuel
valls ont une culture socialiste qui se
rappelle ce que c'était c'est le chaînon
manquant entre les jacobins et les
bolchéviques comme par hasard les
blanquistes sont d'abord où aux côtés du
général boulanger convenir pour la
moitié d'entre eux y compris les
héritiers de blanqui donc ils font le
choix populiste alors qu'ils sont
communards des communards boulangiste y
en a plein saut ça se dit jamais et des
communards antisémite il y en a pas mal
elle a pas mal j'en ai même découvert
depuis l'écriture du livre cette
effarante des quelques communes heures
qui croit clairement que l'histoire du
monde c'est la lutte entre les sémites
et les aryens avec un y faut penser à ça
donc il ya une tradition d'extrême
gauche anti juives qui est symétrique de
la tradition d'extrême droite ces
diables les deux sites les deux anti
système qui sont à la fois victimes et
piqué espère prendre leur revanche sur
les traditionalistes et les socialistes
comme il est évident ils peuvent
converger sur le dos des juifs à la
tendance est aujourd'hui sur l'état
d'israël c'est pain bénit si j'ose dire
et grecs des socialistes qui refusent de
défendre et fussent jaurès fait le pas
mais d'autres refusent parce que dreyfus
c'est un bourgeois c'est un militaire en
plus être un juif alors avec des mines
de fer de jochen jaurès dit on aurait dû
le condamne à man oui alors frédéric
salat-baroux
par rapport à mitterrand qui ne s'est
pas véritablement prononcer sur la
question de vichy de la responsabilité
comme et à jacques chirac lui marque une
rupture avec le discours du vel d'hiv
est-ce que vous pensez que ce discours
du vel d'hiv qui marque la
responsabilité de vichy dans la
déportation de juifs y compris français
est remis en cause aujourd'hui par
certains politiciens comme ericsson
le discours de jacques chirac tranche
avec c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
mitterrand à 17 françois mitterrand
avait cette position avec une forme de
tradition héritée de ce que le général
de gaulle avait dû faire pendant la
guerre c'est à dire affirmé que pétain
n'existe que vichy n'existait pas en
tant que régime et qu'en réalité la
république en jambes et vichy la
particularité du choix de jacques chirac
sait qu'il a
avec le recul du temps et la culture qui
était la sienne considéré qu'il était
temps de nommer les choses comme elles
l'étaient c'est à dire qu'il y avait une
responsable compte inuits et et une
responsabilité de la france de de l'état
français qui à ce jour là commis
l'irréparable
au moment là de la rafle du vel d'hiv
donc c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
un mouvement très profond et se disent
qu est une rupture dans le cycle
historique de l'après-guerre et au sein
de hausse 1 du mouvement gaulliste mais
on voit derrière la remise en cause du
discours du vel d'hiv effectivement et
c'est très bien expliqué dans l'essai de
manuel valls e sur zemmour la volonté au
fond de deux heureux de relativiser
l'histoire c'est de dire en réalité
c'est la théorie du blavet dubout qui
est l'utilité de péta par rapport à de
gaulle et au fond de relativiser cette
période pour avec quel objectif c'est de
dire qu'en réalité la frontière qui
était infranchissable entre la droite et
l'extrême droite entre pétain et de
gaulle en réalité n'est pas
infranchissable par qu'ils auraient au
fond eu un rôle complémentaire donc ça
va bien au delà du discours du vel d'hiv
toute la construction d'eric zemmour
consiste à dire cette construction
cette étanchéité entre la droite et
l'extrême droite est historiquement
fosse est donc aujourd'hui passons à
autre chose passons à l'union ce qu ils
appellent l'union des droites ce qui est
d'ailleurs n'est pas l'union des droites
mais deux une partie de la droite et de
l'extrême droite et je vais plus loin ce
qu ils appellent l'union des droites
n'est que l'union de l'extrême droite la
droite
ne sera sera toujours comme
originalement avec le général de gaulle
le premier et le plus implacable ennemi
de l'extrême droite donc là il ya
quelque chose de très profond qui va au
delà du discours du vel d'hiv alors
cette uchronie antisémite est ce qu'elle
est consubstantielle
à l'extrême droite c'est à dire que
l'extrême droite a besoin de se ferme
antisémite pour exister se constituer en
france comme d'ailleurs dans d'autres
pays européens notamment en europe de
l'est
l'extrême droite
originellement sur sa forme actuelle au
montant donc la fin du 10ème siècle et
nationalistes donc à des tendances
xénophobes qui peuvent se manifester
dans alors pour le coup l'antisémitisme
par l'anti judaïsme mais je précise
quand même que c'est plus complexe car
prenez le fascisme italien contrairement
au fascisme jaillir austro-allemande
hitler lui est complètement antisémite
dès la première seconde le fascisme
italien n'est pas du tout explicitement
antisémite la première le prg le premier
intellectuel fasciste est une femme est
juive c'est margherita sarfatti un
docteur de boussole à l'auteur de the
hunter 2 doubles sauts tout simple et on
a des collègues qui sont des
spécialistes de l'histoire de l'italie à
l'époque fasciste ont calculé que
proportionnellement il ya plus de juifs
dans le parti fasciste que dans la
société italienne sont pas de très
nombreux d'ailleurs c'est à dire qu'on
est tellement intégrée que on a le droit
de haïr et d'être nationaliste avec les
autres sauf que ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que mussolini va
s'aligner sur hitler donc on a
maintenant une sorte de logique
totalitaire qui fait que ça broye après
tout staline après la seconde guerre
mondiale va présider un retour en force
de l'antisémitisme juste un poids de
l'histoire comment vous expliquez manuel
valls que franco n'est pas céder à
l'antisémitisme dans sa criminalité
hitlérienne si on peut dire parce que
c'est une question absente c'est nier en
espagne qui ne se pose pas même s'il
faut quand même rappeler que le discours
de franco et de l'église catholique qui
le soutient dans sa croisade tient un
discours général sur le complot
judéo-maçonnique bolchévique et donc il
ya une alimentation mais sans doute
parce que c'est pas une question
peut-être parce qu'il ya des gens aussi
dans son entourage il ne cède pas sur
cette question alors aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup dans le versant du
versant
antisioniste antisémite en le reliant à
l'islamisme radical qu'est ce que vous
en pensez membres à gaza parce que c'est
c'est devenu le l'antisémitisme moderne
aujourd'hui celui qui vient de cet
islamisme radical
je sais que vous n'êtes pas historienne
mais vous suivez l'actualité je suis
quelque chose du philosophe et c'est pas
très facile de se débrouiller dans c'est
dans ces mots là oui
les monts du sens quand il dit qu'on
instrumentalise et et comment mais s'ils
voulaient je pense qu'il ya des faits
intolérables
d'accord
on est tous d'accord pour dire que la
shoah ça a été
un séisme
et de l'intolérable et on est aussi
d'accord peut-être je crois pour dire
qu'il y a des faits intolérables
pas du tout même niveau pas du tout
comme crime contre l'humanité n'est pas
très loin avec disons des réactions
israéliennes
contre la contre les palestiniens je
dirais pas contre la palestine mais
sabra et chatila c'était pas beau il ya
des choses qui sont vraiment été fait
par les phalanges chrétiennes oui bon ça
a été fait mais ça a été fait on va dire
il ya un ensemble de faits qui sont
difficiles à avaler pour
disons pour des citoyens
j'allais dire
impartiaux en bauges bon et donc je
pense que mettre en balance alors on ne
peut pas balancer shoah et
lutte contre les palestiniens qui
seraient par ailleurs quand même un peu
chez eux en israël et en tout cas assez
chez eux en palestine bon je ne dis pas
qu'il faille balance et je dis qu'il
faut entendre et pour moi
je ne vois pas comment on va s'en sortir
je ne vois pas simplement il ya un autre
un autre moment dans ce que j'ai pu voir
au fer où je ne voyais pas comment on
pouvait s'en sortir c'était en afrique
du sud au moment de l'apartheid et là on
s'en est sorti ils s'en sont sortis
génialement avec la commission vérité
réconciliation
moi je n'imagine rien d'autre rien de
moins mais je ne dis pas que ce soit
faisable pour que
disons il n'est pour vous c'est pas un
progrès que le gouvernement israélien
aujourd'hui et en son sein un parti
arabe islamique très bien très bien
c'est un progrès qu'il y ait des arabes
dans la majorité dans la majorité très
bien de même si c'est un peu c'est un
progrès pas vous interromps parce que
comme l'émission cours à sa fin mais sur
ce point là manuel valls islamisme
antisionisme vous voyez un lien direct
vous dans le djihadisme dans l'islam
politique dans l'islamisme la haine
d'israël la haine des juifs et
l'antisémitisme est un des éléments
fondamentaux de sa matrice on le
retrouve partout avec évidemment une
lecture de l'islam on retrouve parfois
chez les salafistes mais c'est un peu
plus compliqué totalement rudimentaire
retour là je primitif et ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens mais c'était un élément
utilisé pour unifier pour unifier dans
les pays arabes mais pour unifier
surtout les populations issues de
l'immigration arabo musulmane en europe
ce que je crois c'est un sujet de
controverse d'actualité c'est que la
question palestinienne
utilisé comme l'os à ronger pour
reprendre votre expression un peu
partout mais que c'est une question
totalement secondaire me semble-t-il par
rapport à la montée en puissance de
l'antisémitisme en pensant toujours que
le but de l'islam politique et du
jihadisme aujourd'hui des organisations
qui raillent ce type et à islamique où
al qaïda c'est l'europe ce n'est
absolument pas évidemment la palestine
c'est l'europe alors on va terminer
cette émission
on a parlé de l'extrême droite la
lepénisation des esprits aujourd'hui
fait concurrence avec la mémorisation
des comportements si on peut utiliser
cette formule mais ça c'est pour
l'extrême droite l'extrême gauche avec
un multiculturalisme
radical une culture voc la cancel
culture et cetera est ce que cette mise
en cause de l'universalité des valeurs
un soubassement antisémite qu'est ce que
vous en pensez pascal ory pense pas que
c'est un soubassement antisémite mais ça
peut avoir une forme antisémite le
soubassement c'est quand même une sorte
de choix de l'identité dans toutes les
familles il nie toutes les familles
politiques se réfugient en ce moment
dans l'identité comme réponse aux défis
contemporains moi ce qui me frappe
beaucoup c'est que le virus est la
preuve de la mondialisation mais la même
année 2020 c'est l'année du break site
il faut quand même dire que l'histoire
du monde sait ça c'est à dire qui a rien
de fatal qui conduisent de la
mondialisation au mondialisme j'aurais
même tendance à penser le contraire et
si on ajoute la prophétie et prophéties
c'est pas un jugement de valeur
fonctionnellement c'est une prophétie
écologistes
comment peut-on penser un seul instant
en tout cas moi je pense pas un seul
instant mais en tant qu'historien c'est
pas d'idéologie politique là que je fais
une que le laps l'apocalypse qu'on nous
prédit en tous les cas il ya le feu au
lac il faut prendre des décisions
drastiques et c est ce qu on imagine que
ça va conduire à plus de démocratie
participative en histoire ça ne se passe
jamais comme ça ça se traduira pas
l'instauration de régimes autoritaires
ces régimes autoritaires sont
généralement identitaire j'ai pas en
train de vous dire ce que je souhaite
mais je voudrais quand même souligner le
bon la prophétie la prophétie très
ambigu de ce côté là merci écoutez il ya
beaucoup de questions encore on pourra
pas épuiser le sujet aujourd'hui je
voudrais vous remercier et présenter une
bibliographie qui a aidé à préparer
cette émission alors pascal ory de la
haine du juif qui vient de sortir chez
bouquins
comment vous le clarifier en deux mots
finalement
je prends la permanence de lentilles de
crise dans l'histoire
oui oui de toute façon et au delà de
l'histoire et au delà de l'histoire
alors manuel valls
zemmour lentilles républicain pourquoi
vous avez fait ce livre là à brett parce
que précisément ces idées infuse au delà
même du score et que jamais l'extrême
droite n'a été aussi puissantes dans les
intentions de vote depuis 150 ans donc
pour vous et moore c'est l'antithèse de
la république oui parce que précise mois
pour lui de réfugiés n'est pas innocent
et il réhabilite pétain alors frédéric
salat baroux je rappelle que vous avez
écrit un pétain de gaulle pour dire que
ça n'était pas la même chose
mais vous avez écrit également un blum
le magnifique on a eu l'occasion d'en
parler et penser comme ça qui peut être
un modèle pour un renouveau politique en
france en tout cas que c'est le modèle
par excellence du juif français c'est à
dire
l'attachement à sa religion et un
patriotisme extrême et sans doute c'est
ce que je dis souvent il aurait trouvé
les mots dans les périodes dans la
période de fractures actuelle
parce que pour lui la citoyenneté la
france le patriotisme était quelque
chose qui avait profondément un sens
voilà l'actualité de blum aujourd'hui
alors barbara cassin le bonheur ça dans
douce à la mort je vous ai jamais
interrogé là-dessus deux mots sur le
titre de ce livre c'est une phrase de
rimbaud que je trouvais horriblement
vrai ou génialement vrai mais je parle
des juifs dans ce livre quand je parle
par exemple de ma mère ouvrant aux
allemands qui venais chercher mon père
et qui lui ont dit oui vous madame on
sait vous allez à l'église et votre mari
et les juifs et ma mère a dit moi épousé
un juif jamais les allemands sont partis
forts intéressants alors je rappelle un
ouvrage de pierre andré taguieff c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup écrit ai
beaucoup réfléchi sur l'antisémitisme
laurie pose la question sortir de
l'antisémitisme il met un point
d'interrogation c'est chez odile jacob
est un livre qui vient d'également de
sortir de pierre birnbaum sur les larmes
de l'histoire c'est un livre sur
l'antisémitisme qui perdure aux états
unis et qui est intéressant à lire parce
que certains ont pensé que
l'antisémitisme n'existerait pas aux
états unis notamment tocqueville n'en
parle pas mais bien de baume dit qu'il
est toujours présent pour les
négationnistes aujourd'hui la principale
centrale n'est pas en france mais aux
états unis mais dieu merci d'aveux se
rappelle pascal ory alors il me reste à
remercier l'équipe d'elle cp qui a
permis la réalisation de cette émission
merci madame merci messieurs d'avoir
apporté un éclairage et je vous promets
qu'on reparlera de ce sujet et je vous
laisse avec cette citation de barack
obama
face à l'antisémitisme
nous sommes tous juifs ce qui rappellera
en et cause qui se disait en france il
ya quelques décennies
[Musique]